people in Bangladesh did they really
sort of feel the effects of climate on
their bodies to them it's not statistics
it's stuff they deal with every day and
these three brick workers the way the
crouching but sort of just dealing with
the elements to me it's a resonates this
note of perseverance there's an
incredible wind about a hit so days are
just literally went and hid behind the
chimney while I sort had to brace myself
in order to just even point the camera I
actually worried about being blown off
into the water because I could hardly
keep myself up right the rain was her
whipping against my camera and I knew
probably I was gonna kill my camera and
the process of taking this picture which
I did after about ten minutes of this
the camera just drowned from the rain
but as I was standing there looking at
these guys I figured this is a moment
that I'm just gonna shoot until the
camera breaks